>> Dana: IT'S A HUGE NIGHT FOR
DEMOCRATS IN WHAT COULD BE A
MAKE OR BREAK MOMENT FOR MANY OF
THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
FIRST UP IN OUR 2020 ROUNDUP,
INSTEAD OF PROJECTING
CONFIDENCE, JOE BIDEN'S TEAM IS
GOING AFTER THE MEDIA.
BIDEN'S CAMP SAYS THE REASON FOR
RECENT NEGATIVE COVERAGES AND
BECAUSE OF ENDLESS GAS, THEY ARE
BLAMING IT ON YOUNG REPORTERS
WHO THINK THE POLITICIAN IS
UNCOOL.
IS HE UNCOOL QUESTION MIGHT
>> Greg: KNOW, HE'S GOT
PROBLEMS AND THE MEDIA IS NOT
DOING JOE ANY FAVORS BY TREATING
HIM LIKE A FABERGE EGG.
HE IS SAYING THEY'RE PICKING ON
HIM.
THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE DOING REVERSE TRUMP.
TAKEN THE SPOTLIGHT AWAY FROM
HIM BECAUSE AT CERTAIN TIMES HE
DOESN'T LOOK HEALTHY OR RIGHT
BUT THEY ARE FATTENING HIM UP
LIKE A PRIZED VEAL FOR TRUMP.
HE IS SITTING IN A TIGHT CAGE
BECAUSE HE IS NOT WORKING THE
MUSCLES AND BECOMING SLOW,
SUCCULENT, AND IT'S GOING TO BE
SO BAD AND THEY REALLY NEED TO
GET HIM OUT OF THERE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT GOING TO LOOK GOOD AND
A YEAR.
>> Jesse: I THINK HE GETS BAD
PRESS BECAUSE HE'S A BAD
CANDIDATE.
HE IS A RELIC, HE'S NOT A
ROCK STAR.
HE WEARS AVIATORS AND KNOWS
BARACK OBAMA.
SO WHAT?
I WOULDN'T WANT TO COVER HIM.
I WOULD RATHER COVER
ELIZABETH WARREN, EVEN
BETO O'ROURKE.
THE GUY IS A GAFFE MACHINE.
HE DOESN'T ATTRACT ANY CROWDS.
I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
IF YOU ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT,
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
HOW MUCH MORE HELP DO YOU NEED?
>> Dana: I'M TAKING A CONTRARY
VIEW.
I THINK THIS IS SIGNS OF LIFE
FROM TEAM BIDEN.
THEY ARE FINALLY ATTACKING
SOMETHING.
ATTACKING THE PRESS, STARTING TO
TACKLE ELIZABETH WARREN EVEN IF
THEY ARE NOT DOING IT DIRECTLY.
THE OP-ED FROM THE FORMER
GOVERNOR OF PENNSYLVANIA, FORMER
DNC CHAIR AND CALLING
ELIZABETH WARREN A HYPOCRITE.
BUT SHE'S NICE.
THAT IS BASICALLY WHAT IT'S
SAYING.
I THINK THAT SHOWS THEY ARE
WILLING TO DO SOME DIRTY WORK
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO USE THEIR
SURROGATES TO DO IT.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE OF IT
TO COME.
>> Katie: DO YOU THINK
ELIZABETH WARREN IS GOING TO GO
AFTER JOE BIDEN TONIGHT NOW THAT
THEY ARE ON THE SAME STAGE?
OR DO YOU THINK SHE WILL PUSH
BIDEN LEFT?
>> Juan: IF SHE WAS GOING TO
GO AFTER ANYONE SHE WOULD GO
AFTER BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Katie: SHE'S ALREADY
BEATING BERNIE SANDERS NOW.
>> Juan: CORRECT.
I THINK THE DYNAMIC TONIGHT IS
EVERYBODY SAYS IT JOE BIDEN IS
IN THE LEAD.
THEY WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM TAKE
A FALL AND BE ABLE TO TAKE SOME
OF HIS VOTES.
BUT DO I THINK ELIZABETH WARREN
WANTS TO BE THE ONE WHO GOT HIS
FINGER PRINTS ON THE VICTIM'S
BACK?
KNOW BECAUSE THAT WOULD HURT HER
WITH FELLOW DEMOCRATS BIG TIME.
IN TERMS OF THIS THING WITH
REPORTERS AND BIDEN, REPORTERS
DIDN'T THINK HILLARY CLINTON WAS
HIP.
THEY DIDN'T THINK DONALD TRUMP
WAS HIP, BUT WAS GOING TO WIN.
GUESS WHAT, TOUGH LUCK,
REPORTERS.
YOU JUST GO OUT THERE AND COVER
THE STORY.
BUT ESPECIALLY REPORTERS ARE
LIKE, BIDEN IS NOT EXCITING.
BIDEN IS NOT OBAMA.
>> Katie: ONE THING THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO WORK IN THIS
POLITICAL AGE IS BEING A PHONY.
ELIZABETH WARREN LOVES ATTACKING
THE WEALTHY BUT SHE HAS NO
PROBLEM TAKING HER     AND THEIR
PROBLEM TAKING HER     AND THEIM
PROBLEM TAKING HER     AND THEIN
PROBLEM TAKING HER     AND THEIY
PEER SHEETS WEALTHY HERSELF
HERSELF AND IS BEING CALLED OUT
FOR HER HYPOCRISY.
SHE TOOK A BUNCH OF CORPORATE
CASH IN 2016 THAT SHE ROLLED
OVER TO HELP ON HER CURRENT
CAMPAIGN.
SHE HAS BEEN ON THIS KICK OF, I
DON'T TAKE CORPORATE MONEY, I'M
ONLY LISTENING TO GRASSROOTS, I
WANT SMALL DONORS BUT SHE IS
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE A LOT OF
CORPORATE MONEY.
>> Greg: EVERY TIME I SEE HER HR
ICY JIMINY CRICKET AND I DON'T
KNOW WHY.
THE PROBLEM IS HER ENTIRE IDEA
OF BANNING FRACKING, TAXING
EVERYBODY TO SPONSOR A TRILLION
DOLLAR FANTASY IS NOT GOING TO
PREVENT AN APOCALYPSE AT ALL.
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO SPEED UP
THE APOCALYPSE BECAUSE OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE GOING TO FILL THE
VOID.
LESS COMPASSIONATE ABOUT THE
EARTH THEN WE ARE.
NOT GOING TO LISTEN TO A
12-YEAR-OLD CLIMATE ACTIVIST AND
TAKE THEIR MARCHING ORDERS FROM
HER.
ONCE WE STEP OFF THE WORLD STAGE
THERE'S GOING TO BE IRAN,
RUSSIA, VENEZUELA WILL ALL STEP
IN, AND THE ENVIRONMENT IS JUST
ANOTHER ROAD BUMP ON THE SPEED
HIGHWAY TO LOVE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Katie: MESSAGING ON THIS
COMMENT TO MARIANNE, THE
DEMOCRATS IN DETROIT TALKED
ABOUT BANNING CARS FOR THE SAKE
OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THEY GOING TO TALK ABOUT
FRACKING IN TEXAS?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING.
YOU ASKED IF ELIZABETH WARREN IS
GOING TO PUSH BIDEN LEFT.
THEY ARE ALREADY LEFT.
HE SAID HE IS GOING TO END
FOSSIL FUELS IN TEN YEARS.
BASICALLY, SINCE THEY HAD THE
LAST DEBATE, ONE OF THE
CANDIDATES THAT WILL BE UP
THERE, ANDREW YANG, TALKED ABOUT
A POSSIBLE MANDATORY BUY BACK OF
YOUR GAS GUZZLING VEHICLE.
AND BE REPLACED BY AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE.
THEY ARE ALREADY THERE AND I
DON'T THINK IT MATTERS BECAUSE
NOW IT IS ALL A NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> Katie: ANDREW YANG IS
SUPPOSEDLY GOING TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF FUN TONIGHT SO
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAS
CHALLENGED PRESIDENT TRUMP ON.
>> DONALD TRUMP, BECAUSE I WOULD
SCHOOL HIM.
DONALD TRUMP?
ON MY GOSH.
HE WOULD BE STANDING THERE I
WOULD BE LIKE, OH, SCORE LEFT,
SCORE RIGHT!
SCORE JUMP SHOT!
>> Katie: TRUMP OR ANDREW YANG
ON THE BASKETBALL COURT?
>> Jesse: HE HAD SOME GAME, I
SAW HIM PLAY A LITTLE BIT.
WHICH IS FINE.
HE CAN HANDLE A NICE JUMP SHOT
BUT ALL THESE THINGS ARE
RESOLVED ON THE GOLF COURSE AND
I THINK TRUMP WOULD SMOKE HIM.
>> Katie: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ACTUALLY TROLLING THE CANDIDATES
TONIGHT.
HIS CAMPAIGN IS GOING TO HAVE A
HUGE BANNER SAYING "SOCIALISM
SUCKS" ESSENTIALLY.
WHO WINS THE ARGUMENT ON
SOCIALISM?
>> Juan: THERE ISN'T ANYTHING
THAT DEMOCRATS COULD DO TO
PREVENT A TRUMP FROM CALLING
THEM SOCIALISTS.
>> Katie: THEY ARE.
>> Juan: THEY ARE NOT
SOCIALISTS.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE WHAT A
SOCIALIST IS, THESE ARE
PEOPLE -- IF YOU SAY SOCIALIST
SECURITY, MEDICARE, MEDICAID IS
SOCIALIST.
I THINK YOU LOSE BIG TIME WITH
AMERICAN VOTERS.
BUT TRUMP, THIS IS TROLLING,
THIS IS SILLINESS.
I HOPE DEMOCRATS DON'T PAY
ATTENTION.
DAVID AXELROD HAD A PIECE TODAY
THAT SAID DON'T LEAD TO TRUMP
GET AWAY WITH THIS KIND OF
STUFF, THIS JIU-JITSU.
USE HIS NEGATIVE ENERGY --
>> Greg: IT'S TOO LATE.
TRUMP HAS INTRODUCED A NEW KIND
OF CAMPAIGNING.
HE IS INTRODUCED THE CONCEPT OF
THE HARLEM GLOBETROTTERS INTO
POLITICS.
WATCH ME COME TO TOWN AND LAST
OF THE GENERALS.
THAT IS    IS WHAT IT IS GOING T
THAT IS    IS WHAT IT IS GOING O
THAT IS    IS WHAT IT IS GOING B
THAT IS    IS WHAT IT IS GOING .
WHEREVER THE DEMOCRATS SHOW UP
HE WILL HAVE A LITTLE WAR ROOM
AND SAY, WHAT CAN WE DO TO MESS
WITH THEM?
YOU CAN'T GO BACK AFTER THIS.
EVEN IF HE LOSES, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE DOING THIS WAY
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Juan: PEOPLE GET TIRED OF
THIS.
IT'S JUST GETTING STARTED.
WE'VE SEEN THIS ACT, FOR NOW.
WE SAW IT IN 2016 AND HE DOESN'T
STOP.
>> Jesse: WHEN YOU ARE ON THE